Square,
welcome to the hall and to tonight's
debate,
which is b,
where the Dragon Africa should not look
at China.
We've got a distinguished panel who
actually introduce one by one as they go
up and speak.
This is a topic which has been something
which has been exercising people here,
I would say for the last five years or
so,
but it's ever more important because
with the European and American
economists flatlining and China's
steaming ahead and African economies
also seeming ahead.
The world is changing and trade between
Africa and China has now reached
$100,000,000,000 a year.
And I read the other day,
uh,
that the US assistant secretary of
state,
Johnny Carson said at some point last
year,
this was a big problem because China was
operating in Africa with no morals and
like everybody else operating in Africa
whose morals I'm sure completely
scrupulous and always have been.
But that does go to the heart of the
debate.
Doesn't set.
Is China a model which has lifted
hundreds of millions of its own people
out of poverty and the Guide and the
benign influence or is trying to
reinforcing corruption,
exploitation?
I think that will be the heart of our
debate tonight.
Now,
you would have been polled as you came
in,
whether you are a fool or against the
motion and you should also have these
voting cards.
And so when the,
uh,
main species of finished and you've had
the chance to ask a few questions
yourself,
people will be coming around with ballot
boxes.
So we would ask you to tear the sleeping
half and vote for or against as you
wish.
If you really can't make your mind up,
then you put a don't know which is the
whole slip.
But I hope that our panelists tonight,
we'll be able to sway you one way or
another.
What's going to happen is everybody's
going to get up and make their speech
for about 10 minutes,
but I'm going to ask each of the
panelists to stay there after finishing
the speech.
And the opposing team will have some
quick fire questions for them.